the one thing we know for sure is that
when it's time to announce the third
overall pick it will not be kyle pitts
tight end florida it will be a
quarterback and that raises the question
of the status of jimmy garoppolo now and
beyond when shanahan spoke with
reporters today got a question gave an
answer about the future of jimmy g here
it is
can you say with certainty that jimmy
garoppolo will be on the roster on
sunday
i can't guarantee that anybody in the
world will be alive sunday so i can't
guarantee who will be on our roster on
sunday um so that goes for all of us
i think he said they're gonna whack
jimmy g
i think they're going to tell jimmy g
he's getting made like somebody pointed
out on twitter take him to that basement
they're going to whack him
uh hey peter look there's a strategic
game that's being played here you
pointed out today that they may be
warming to the idea of trading jimmy
garoppolo i think it's important to get
him out of the building because you got
guys on that team that are pro jimmy
garoppolo you don't want to have some
sort of a schism in your locker room
between the guys who line up behind
garoppolo and the guys who line up
behind mac jones trade lance justin
fields whoever i think it's critical
that they make a move and i think the
big wild card in all that is finding
someone who would take 25 million on in
compensation or get garoppolo to take
less to facilitate a trade but i i
understand saying what he's saying i
can't imagine going all in with this
quarterback and keeping garoppolo for
another year
after you've gone through all this
to get the guy who's going to be your
future
yeah i've i've really
um
i i've i've really been straddling a
line on this one mike because i agree
with the 49ers when they originally made
this trade
they wanted to make sure that they were
not going to be one quarterback injury
away from their season being over
and so you know and so therefore
let jimmy garoppolo start the season
and hey if he's three and four
you know by the middle of october or
halloween whenever
whenever that comes around
basically then you know the new guy
takes the job
but the problem has come in
recently
that
every time that they've had to play the
backup quarterback disaster strikes and
they're just not a very good team
anymore so
i i mean i still think i understand why
you might want
uh
you know why you might want garoppolo
out of the building
but i also understand a very big reason
why you'd want him in the building and
that is
you you've three of your four seasons
have collapsed in failure they've won
six six and four games in three of their
four seasons they've had three of their
four seasons they've been losing seasons
you know and and not not pretty ones so
i would still favor keeping uh jimmy
garoppolo and having kyle shanahan
have a very difficult conversation with
him before the first day of training
camp saying
gotta put your big boy pants on this
year buddy and we know what the future
holds you control
what your future holds
you control it by playing great
so in 2022 and beyond maybe you're in a
dream place for you and you can stick it
up our rear ends
and the key for garoppolo is going to be
staying on the field after missing 23
games over the last three seasons
proving to others
that he can
stay healthy that he can put in full
seasons and he can maybe generate some
trade value for the 49ers after 2021 if
they decide to go forward the other
scenario peter is the sam bradford
scenario that the eagles had unfold for
them back in 2016 where you never know
when that quarterback's going to get
injured and the skies are going to open
and a first round pick and a fourth
round pick are going to fall out of them
because you have a playoff contender
whose starter and teddy bridgewater
suddenly tore an acl and they're
scrambling to find a quarterback and you
never know when that's going to happen
so that's another reason to hang on to
him because you could end up getting a
lot more later than whatever you would
get on draft weekend
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports